America's coronavirus crisis is growing
more than 1300 people are known to be
sick from the virus in the u.s.
thirty-nine have died there are more
than 127 thousand cases and 4700 dead
worldwide all but eight of America's
deaths have been in Washington State
where officials are now taking drastic
steps to stop the spread Jonathan
Vigliotti is in Seattle Jonathan good
morning and good morning to you Anthony
Governor Inslee saying there is no
silver bullet to kill this virus but he
hopes his measures will help save lives
effective immediately all gatherings
over 250 people have been banned schools
like the one behind me also impacted
take a listen public leisure faith-based
or sporting events parades concerts
festivals conventions fundraisers and
similar activities of that dimension are
prohibited as we go forward and shortly
after that announcement was made Seattle
Public Schools announced they were
called canceling all 114 schools 53,000
students are impacted and what's
happening here in Washington having a
ripple effect South in Oregon officials
late last night making a similar ban of
groups over 250 people here in
Washington State this has been the
epicenter as officials have struggled to
contain this virus there are now 31
known coronavirus deaths and more than
365 confirmed cases hardest hit are
nursing homes 23 of those deaths linked
to the life care facility where we have
been reporting from in Kirkland for the
past two weeks we can now report
everyone has been tested 63 people have
tested positive the National Guard is
being brought in here to the state to
help with medical supplies the governor
warning that this ban could extend
through April and to give some context
nearly four million people are impacted
by the ban back to you
alright Jonathan thank you very much
less